qu'est ce qu'un commentaire nous entrons
dans ce que sont les écoles de
commentaires youtube une discussion
c'est vrai qu'internet et les rires et
les nouvelles technologies progresse de
manière assez exponentielle et mon cours
consiste simplement à mettre à la page
les personnes âgées n'ayant pas suivi
cette évolution linguistiques afin de
leur éviter un décalage majeur
lorsqu'elle commente une vidéo youtube
en gros vous êtes prof de commentaires
youtube
voilà c'est ça mais je lui dis bon
gentil l'orbiquet j'lâche d'amandine que
je laisse les grandes gueules qui permet
toutes les gares un commentaire mais
jeter dans l'ensemble c'est formidable
mais je trouvais que le groupe o et il
est un petit peu fort de café
toutes ces insanités excès ce monsieur
baky c'est le barbeau c'est un cabotin
en revanche il a de très jolis chaîne
alors c'était très intéressant mais
celle concernant tout ce qui est barbeau
cabotin ça pourrait plus se traduire
peut-être par jacques bolos bolos
quoiqu'un peu générique michel 1 mais ça
passe ça va oui je rame un peu trop
patati patata
qui ça s'est fait hier tous
pour revenir à cette histoire de chaîne
comment on pourrait dire
qu'effectivement ce jeune homme a de
très belles chaises soir soit guy la
callas soyez la callas frères x2 à bas
n'ont pas exhibé puisque xd ça vient
après un complément ça fonctionne pas
quand il ya l'impératif ou le négatif
juste avant comme par exemple dans
manche tâche ne mange ta schleck ça on
peut pas bon en face on aura l'occasion
de reparler de tout ça je vous dis à
demain et rend très bien et surtout xo
cybergun progressé tellement vite